relatives of two americans who are
imprisoned in russia were at the white
house on friday the families of paul
whelan held on what the u.s says are
false espionage charges and wnba star
brittany griner met with president biden
greiner was arrested in february for
possession of cannabis oil the
administration says it has offered a
prisoner swap for the two americans but
so far there has been little progress
christina rafini is at the white house
with the latest christina good morning
good morning dana there were no cameras
but this was the first meeting for the
family of paul whelan and the president
now paul has been detained in russia for
almost four years in a statement after
the meetings the white house said the
conditions of these americans being
detained is intolerable and that the
president told these families when it
comes to their loved ones every minute
they're being held is a minute too long
[Music]
while the two americans endure another
day in diplomatic limbo we want these
two individuals home back where they
belong with their families they should
be there already the biden
administration says it's doing what it
can to negotiate the release of
basketball star brittany griner and
former marine paul whelan from russian
prisons sources tell cbs news that
includes offering a prisoner swap for a
notorious russian arms dealer victor
boot currently in u.s custody we have
made a serious offer
to get
brittany grinder and paul whalen back
home the russians have not responded to
that offer but that doesn't mean that
we're not still in negotiations and
we're not still trying a third american
trevor reed was released in a prisoner
swap in april after nearly a thousand
days in russian prisons the detention
facility where
brittany griner is being held is
probably going to be significantly
better than the forced labor camp where
paul is currently being held earlier
this week on cbs mornings he shared a
message for wieland and griner the
highest levels of the u.s government are
are attempting to get you out so so keep
the faith
secretary of state anthony blinken said
yesterday bringing wrongly detained
americans home in russia or anywhere
around the world is a top priority just
because we don't say something or you
don't see something doesn't mean it's
not happening so we are working on it
also complicating matters the u.s
doesn't currently have an ambassador to
russia the man who was there
long-serving diplomat who was actually a
holdover from the trump administration
had to come back to the sudden death of
his wife so whoever the u.s
administration chooses as their next
candidate they have to submit those
credentials to the government in moscow
and as you might imagine michelle
bureaucratic delays are likely to ensue
wow christina thank you